how do you assign value what is value I
saw it you had Puma socks and I my brain
goes to those are 37 Cent socks that he
paid nine bucks for because it has four
letters in the same order with the same
logo and it means something so you know
for me that's just how the entire world
works well Gary it is such a pleasure to
be here with you today here at Art basil
thank you so much for your time happy to
be here thanks for having me you know I
wanted to start off for those here at
basil tell us about VSCO you know this
event and what you want people to to
walk away with here you know in general
when I do things with my companies
whether it's veiner X which is the
holding company that has vaynermedia and
Vayner 3 which are two of the more
prominent people playing at me uh or V
friends which is my intellectual
property out of T project
when we do things like basil or you know
and being All-Star or Super Bowl or can
or South by really what you're what I'm
always thinking about is how do we
reverse engineer uh a scenario an
activation uh a collaboration or an
event space or that creates Serendipity
conversation relationship building I
think of it from a Karma standpoint I
think a lot about
um intent I think too many business
people and companies when they're
activating and things like this are too
transactional right like we're gonna do
this thing and we're gonna bring our
clients and we're gonna get the money I
just don't think like I think humans can
sense that and so I kind of go
completely the other way which is like
how do we do something that brings so
much value to anybody that comes
whether it's a personality that's there
to mingle with other brands right uh I
mean I go so Extreme as like inviting
competitors to see if they can like
steal our like I get that crazy with it
so
you know what do what do I think about
like what what's the punch line the
punch line is how much Karma can you put
into the system during a time where a
lot of people congregate to the same
area sure and and turning to the concept
of Ip yeah you've been very vocal about
that how do you assign value what is
value when it comes to determining that
that perceived value from a consumer
perspective of any particular piece of
Ip that you have whether it's V friends
whether it's you know this NBA All-Star
it's it's the only thing I think about
like your Puma socks like literally I
already I saw I I like when we were just
I saw you had Puma socks and I my brain
goes to those are 37 Cent socks
yeah that he paid nine bucks for because
it has four letters in the same order
with the same logo and it means
something
so you know for me that's just how the
entire world works
this
is a bottle of water
this was free
for a drillion years and then somewhere
about 50 years ago someone's like wait a
minute I'm gonna sell something that is
actually free
and if I can make the brand mean
something
people will actually pay a lot of money
for something that to remind everybody
water was free and every faucet and so I
think it's the only thing I think it's
how monarchies or capitalism or
democracy or communism or dictator's
work I think it's how people parent all
I think about is IP you know all I think
about is comms and marketing and how
things work and and then and then for me
specifically in the journey I'm on
my driver for building out my IP
selfishly is about oh I think I can
build a big business
selflessly
um I think about if I can create 300
characters in a Pokemon Sesame Street
marvel-like world where I can do what
I've done for 15 years as garyvee and
pushed kindness patience empathy
well that's been hard
you know garyvee is a very specific
human being who's gonna work for some
people and it's not going to work for
others
but this patient Panda might be more
effective of teaching people patience
than me
and so for me I'm really enjoying the
building out of the intellectual
property and I want to really leave a
legacy I'm very very affected as I
become more educated on how Jim Henson
saw the world and what what his Muppets
not only Sesame Street but fraggle do
you know fraggle rocks absolutely so
fraggle rocks brief
AKA when it was handed to the woman that
started the process of deciding what
Fraggle Rock was going to be the brief
like what are we trying to accomplish
was stop War
that's profound and I'm very affected by
that and I think a lot about that and so
um I think about IP as something that
can really bring a lot of value to both
the person that created it and to the
people that are using it for example
stop war is very like up here but Puma I
like that there's a brand called Puma
that made a sock that like for you it's
a form of expression right like you're
like all of us are dressed right now to
communicate right tattoos to communicate
right that's a Nintendo reference like
that that I'm I'm able to understand you
more in a hyper second
just by what IP you're communicating to
me right now we're all walking Brands a
hundred percent you've said several
times you know how does that translate
to be friends and scalability and how
you are taking this entire portfolio
involved of of imagery Nostalgia and
assets to that next level
it it creates a North star of like I
have a very good sense of what I'm up to
I desperately want the world to fall in
love with a countable ant because I
think accountability if you fall in love
with it before you're 18 will lead to
less anxiety and depression
so it's very clear then to answer your
question then I start thinking about
what brand like why forthright I
struggled with Candor my whole whole
life I'm doing a very cool collaboration
right now with a very cool brand and
it's the fourth right flamingo
so cool you could see vintage frames and
it's rad and it's fresh and I'm
gonna rock it and you can see the be
friends that I've got glasses garyvee
that's cool to me because I'm an
entrepreneur five fine but over time
it's like it's the fourth right flamingo
it's the fourth right flamingo and it's
like wait a minute like is being
forthright a good thing oh wow it is
actually if you keep it in balance and
you deliver it with kindness and so like
there are millions of people around the
world like myself who have struggled
with Candor which has led to the things
that have made them unhappy and if I can
story tell through collaborations
through you know sneaker deals and and
glasses or more directly children's
books
um movies television streaming services
toys with QR codes that let you watch a
four minute video the Coco melon
execution of all YouTube the The Adult
Swim Rick and Morty execution of
Television thing like Bart Simpson and
everything in between Hello Kitty well
then over time for the back half of my
life the next 47 years of my life I
think I can leave a really meaningful
impact and so
I think very vigorously about every
collaboration why what how
um and who which which character is
going to be my cereal I think about
probably once a week once a week in my
day-to-day navigation I will give three
minutes to 40 minutes of meaningful time
of like what's the one because I know
it's gonna work because I know how to
sell stuff and I'm gonna do that well
and I'm going to sell cereal but I need
to be very thoughtful of am I going to
make that a very healthy clean cereal
that may skew for 25 year old Coastal
like you know thinkers of food that way
or am I going to make a sugar cereal
that's just a little fun a little
escapism for nine-year-old you gotta
capture that Nostalgia it's what
resonates right it's it's what feels
right we've all grown up with these
Collectibles the Pokemon cards the Hot
Wheels right and now we have this new
technology nfts right but it's not
really different it's just in a new
medium and I think 100 is keeping
getting rid of the labels to an extent
you know but still maintaining that
tastefulness is something that I feel
that you've integrated into everything
that you're doing what you just shared
want to extract that cultural feeling
that a child whether they're eight or
ten years old feels comfortable with
that they can point and say I like this
I don't know why but I like it or
especially especially if that eight or
ten-year-old's like I like this I like
this I like this oh wait a minute this
attribute of kindness is something I
want to be about right right for a 25
year old it might be you know it might
be cooler like you for a kid it might be
I'm interested in this I don't know why
for a 40 year old it might be like I'm
interested in this I don't know why to
your point it's all that integration and
so what I'm most excited about is even
before I launched it I gave a lot of
thought to I'm going to build a very big
universe so I can play with this canvas
forever and so I didn't draw Mickey
Mouse and then like like and then ha and
then later I built Pluto or or Daisy
Duck from day one there was 268
characters because I knew what I wanted
to do which is build a universe that
will leave a positive impact and it's
execution of becoming pop culture how
does fashion play into the V friends
ecosystem and what you're continuing to
build out over time I mean look I'm like
this is a great answer to this question
first
the the
humbleness and joy I feel of doing a
high Beast interview
speaks to how fashion plays meaning what
does that mean it means that fashion
like music and Sport and religion
and a couple of other things are is like
one of the most foundational human
experiences
I would argue that the singular reason I
knew nfts will play out long term is
because fashion and art 100
we we communicate through the things we
buy
um so fashion specifically has been
probably the place I've been most
aggressive the brand is different is 18
months old Reebok starter
kinshui
right carrots
vintage frames I mean like it's
disproportionately ahead of almost
everything out of anything else I've
done so far I haven't done as many
consumer package Goods I haven't done
this much content fashion collaborations
have been the thing that I've been
running fastest with
because I because I because on strategy
I myself have such a large audience 15
to 45. many of which like care about
fashion and so and it's also been really
fun personally to put on my collab
Partners I also feel that I want to be
the best collaboration partner so to me
whether it's starter or carrots or
vintage frames I have a very large
universe and the fact that I'm able to
bring that relevance and that audience
to them
excites me the fact that I'm gonna go
downstairs right now and have lines of
people who are going to come to
collaboration but then they're going to
be like wait a minute I like those
glasses better than even the V friends
glasses that's good for vintage frames
that makes me happy so Fashion's a fun
place plus with fashion and you know
this and definitely the readers of this
publication know this limited is good
and so you're able to do lots of little
stuff it's fun to do a buck 50 run of
this or a thousand of that and so
um it allows for almost like Tapas
instead of like a big meal like it's not
like you could do it quick and
thoughtful but in six months something
can be in Market in a great way whereas
when you're thinking about toys like I'm
doing or I mean animation it's like a
three-year Journey for me I'm
like oh be a hundred you know like you
know so like so I think uh that's
another reason I gravitate towards it
speed is an incredibly important thing
to me and I love that through
collaborations we can get into Market
within a six or nine month period so
with with that how do you define culture
we all use the word we all throw it out
there but what does culture mean to you
garyvee culture for me uh my brain goes
to putting the word pop
in like every time it's like this is
culture and then my brain goes popular
pop culture and then my brain goes
popular culture and and what that means
to me is people are interested in
you know I think the word slang today
speaks a lot about Urban culture speaks
a lot about cool culture speaks a lot
about it being a hype Beast actually a
hype Beast but I but I do think
sometimes people
miss the bigger macro so for example
I'll give you a good example lately I've
been thinking a lot about how I want to
do things with be friends in fishing
culture right like like the millions of
people who wake up at 5am across the
country in the world
and go fishing and it is the most
important thing to them and so like to
me like do I want to get fishing boots
and with one of my C characters like
that's a culture but I don't think we in
a hype Beast way think of when we say
culture we don't think that we don't
think hunting and fishing we think cool
but for a lot of people hunting and
fishing is the coolest and so like I
remember thinking that video games were
going to be so much bigger than a lot of
my friends saw I just knew I was like
this is not a thing that is just for
kids because we were growing up with it
I'm like why are we still playing this
in college and it's like even more
important now than it was when we were
nine I'm like this is big this is a
culture so I think of it very macro so
that's how I Define it let's get into
the why too right always for the Y
always to the Y producer needs to be a
reason for it and to that how do you
inject tastefulness in the Partnerships
and collaborations that you enter into
or bring these friends into hey I'm not
crippled by the concept of tastefulness
because I know that it's everyone's
subjective opinion
you know and so one the way I bring
tastefulness is I'm not scared of it
where I think a lot of people are scared
of it they want it to be tasteful to
taste makers I'm not worried about that
uh I try to build bring tastefulness uh
to the table through intent I want to
make a great product
I want to make something that people
really enjoy that they have it
I have no interest in anybody buying it
if it's not something that brings them
value
so I kind of bring a very strong intent
based energy and then the tastefulness
in the way we Define it is like I have a
subjective creative opinion
I think something looks cool uh I know
that that means millions of others will
I also know that that means millions of
others won't think that's cool uh and
that's fine
um
and so
I think a lot of people are crippled by
taste full and they become
perfectionists and they become insecure
and they become like crippled and they
don't do
you know to me as long as I have good
intent
uh and value my opinion
while recognizing that that opinion
doesn't mean anything to 70 of the world
uh in in every subjective call I make
then that's great that's fine it's not
vintage frames and and the upcoming
event today
um what what's most exciting you about
this and and why why so many people here
you know I think the most exciting thing
on the collaboration like vintage frames
their DNA core like like what I really
respect them is they come from the
streets and hustle of garage sale flea
market like I do so that connection was
right off the top the fact that he is
still out there going to like you know
estate sales and like buying seven glass
I just can't resonate with that more so
that was one two I wanted to go into
eyewear and play with it you know
there's a lot of categories I'm going to
play in that I'm not a heavy user of I
don't wear glasses I don't tend to like
the number one thing most of my friends
and family make fun of me for is I don't
wear shades in the sun ever
so it wasn't like oh I need this for me
I'm like I may not but you guys do and
so that was exciting for me
um
I also
spoke to and have spoken to tons of uh
creative
uh individuals in the fashion industry
and really wanted to go on my intuition
on who would be partners I wanted to
work with one of the things that's
interesting about this because I just
spoke to this this took the longest time
why because on the Vintage frame side
they wanted it right from their
perspective and what I liked was
even you know it's funny my macro thesis
of why I want to do a lot of stuff in
fashion collabs is the speed
I liked when I started partnering with
them where I could feel like oh wait a
minute they're like no no we're
scrapping that whole three months we are
I liked that I respected their creative
process so much that I was comfortable
that it took us six months or nine
months later than I had in my ideology
the product came out great the other
most exciting part is any excuse I can
have
to meet up
with people that want to go out of their
way to say hello to me is something
that's interesting to me
so I'll have my hardest core fans
you know down there like
obviously a group of 10 to 50
individuals that make me feel like I'm
the Grateful Dead or fish I'm like
they're everywhere they're at everything
and it's just like I don't even know how
to express in words even though I'm a
pretty solid Communicator what it feels
like when people will go out of their
way to show up anywhere and everywhere
you are publicly to you know get a few
more minutes to say hello to ask a
question to take us they're 19 selfie
it's it's profoundly humbling and then
equally because that's over here equally
sending a text the last couple days to
the 10 000 people that live within a 30
mile radius of this location which is
actually roughly the numbers I have on
my community text Community the amount
of people that reply to like this is
gonna be the first time I'm ever gonna
see you because I've not been able to
travel or I can't afford to go to vcon
or go to the sports card convention in
New Jersey I just happen to live 20
minutes from here I can't wait to see
you that is profoundly exciting for me
so on those two extremes I get very
excited which is why I tend to probably
do a lot of public events and that is
very exciting about this collaboration
that was very important to me of like we
were talking through it's not just like
we're going to sell the sun.com let's
have an in-person
uh partial of this oh wait your your HQ
is Miami oh wait Basel is a big part of
nft culture oh let's aim for doing
something in December and now here we
are absolutely my last last two
questions for you if you could change
anything about the law surrounding IP
and digital Collectibles what would you
want to see changed
if anything you know IP I'm very
comfortable with I think that's
established law for a long time
I think with digital Collectibles I'm
empathetic to the government I think
humans just really love the on
governments uh I'm just empathetic I'm
aware why we don't have clarification of
law it's called Innovation is faster
than government
but what would I like to see I would
like to see in the next half decade very
clear laws from The Sovereign Nations
around the world on how they are looking
to handle an nft uh specifically for me
because that's where I have my passion
but cryptocurrency like let's get some
thoughtful logical Common Sense laws
around the world so that operators
entrepreneurs governments uh established
businesses can start moving faster
because when it's gray people are not
sure what to do right
for those that may be attending our
basil for the first time or the younger
Generations that are finally taking an
interest in in art for For the First
Time what advice do you have for them as
they come into your event and this week
you know this weekend Festival what what
mindset should they be focused on two
things stand out one
even for the most introverted challenge
yourself to say hello to as many people
as possible the number one Roi of things
like Basel can South by Southwest is the
Serendipity of relationship and that is
even more profound now because we're
just getting out of a coveted era right
where for two years there was no
Serendipity we were very efficient in
this meeting that meeting this morning
but the stumbling into somebody and
becoming friends or business associates
was eliminated so if you're coming here
try not to just run in the same circles
expand your circles and Challengers say
self to say hello to somebody and if
they're they don't reciprocate that's an
indication of them not you don't feel
bad because somebody shoes you off or
like hurts your feelings don't have your
feelings hurt when somebody's not kind
that means they're not in a good place
that's number one number two
when it comes to art for youngsters at
ft's physical art Collectibles sneakers
stop buying based on other people's
opinions
do not buy things to keep up with the
Joneses do not buy things because
everybody else thinks Andy Warhol is
cool you think any world's cool if you
think any more whole I'll give you a
good one I think Jackson Pollock is
now do I really I'm saying that a little
bit to be like a little hyperbolized in
a more truthful way I can't wrap my head
around spending a hundred million
dollars for a Jackson Pollock painting I
don't I can't wrap my head around
spending ten thousand dollars for
something that looks like a Jackson
Pollock because I don't like that style
but I may like a different style so I
think people have to get more
comfortable liking what they like don't
buy a v friend because garyvee like buy
a friend if you actually just like it
like I'm into empathy and the empathy
elephant speaks to me and I like Doodles
I actually like that style of art more
than something that's more polished or
by a world of women or buy an x copy or
buy you know a Robert Nava physical like
buy what you like for as long as humanly
possible because then it will become
your natural place and that will be far
more joyful than keeping up with the
Joneses and needing a Rasheed because
everyone has a machine painting or
needing a board Aid because everybody
cool like that puts people in bad places
that's the reason people buy Mercedes
and burka bags when they don't really
even want it if they're just using it to
signal and usually it's a signal of
insecurity well it's it's that why you
know even for lawyers it's getting to
the wine if you don't know your why you
don't have to finish action and you're
just wasting time 100 reasons that's
right Gary want to thank you so much
thank you brother I appreciate it cheers
[Music]
foreign